あそういやそいやそいやそいやそれや
て込んだ机が今日は外れ社長ですや造膜せしました質問コーナーですぅードンマイも夏
も終わるということですねこれはなんとね約10万件のコメント質問頂い
ていました本当にありがとうございます枚か言うんですけどすべてのコメントには答え
られないんですけども
脳でなんとピックアップさせて頂いたコメントに応えていこうと思いますよかったらお
付き合いくださいませ
ねアイコンなんかも初見です実は食べに彼はに入れますねわたしとヤらない書かれ
一歩ヘッポコぼこぴっなりたいんですけど4件か何
が元気でございますちょっとした気遣いのあるコメントで僕は助かっています皆さん
いつもありがとうございますもうこんなにコメントが多分無理だっていうのか
もしかしたらはいをされるんですよコメントで諦めてる人が多いぞ
質問コーナーは諦めたら負けだ作らちんちん見せてやだどんなバイトしたことある
大学生
今からしたいねんけど教えてくれ僕がだいぶと h 23年生の時ですね
コンビニのバイト家庭教師テレビ局のアシスタントのバイト屋台のバイト後イベントの
ねお手伝いとか
短期でね色んなバイトを発見でやってましたもう
何なんですか大江をよく見るぞ何なんですかって言ったら採用されてと思ってるやつ
今回は採用しナンデスカーンなんですよなんだなんだ売れそうなんですか
そうなんですようまるちゃんの真似して
んああああ
ハートドアプラモデルじゃねぇスイカよってくれ cm で即件してください
うん造影
うるさいん
ああああああ
乳首の数だけ手拍子を舐めてあなたがそうめん食べてください俺の中では一部と
いただきます
和美社長はフォトブック定価1200円+税8月28日金曜日講談社から発売を始め
社長のフォトグって食べますぜひ皆さんよかったら買ってみてね
かっこいいこと言いながら俺がに切ってくださいはっはー
哀れなものかなぁ
動力を持たぬ人間というものを運命と定めとまぁ
花でパズドラやってください
[音楽]
てですプラージュをしながら右足で発通してだけで妄想してください
muta 飽海朝からでれーぶれーとまわしてみてください
ua 僕は今男子校に通っているのですがそもそも女子との出会いがないため彼女が
できません
唯一女子と関われる文化祭でもコミュ障なのでナンパすらできません
どうすれば彼女ができますか女子校回打ってます
めっちゃ共感だ
事故もそんな感じなんですねじゃあ僕と付き合いましょういいですね
a 全力でうちらのサウンドを真似してくださいあああ
スウープ
スプーンたーーーー三者ラリー
ええええええ
[拍手]
ああああああ
まじか海にで人増の音など書いてください髪の毛ロングの b さんの白いワンピース
で髪の毛はロングがねちょっと古いクリッとした白いワンピースですね
理想のスタイルです私に内緒にしていることなんでしょ次いで4速報こうしてみたと
いう動画があるんですけどもそれだ最後にねケツの穴に本当に注意が刺さっちゃって
めっちゃ痛がってたんですけど味ツアー
穴が裂けちゃって違うとマンだけなんて記述する以外痛くて救急で病院に行きました
かなり重症で23日まともに動けなかったです猫ネーションはい俺のターンドロー
はじめの没で多いぷくぷー serfas
スタースぺちょパパナメっつっ
はいチョコボール口に潰れるだけ詰めて
注い折り合おうその書士井端をだよそれぞれその香り
椎葉どうぞ4妻
入った穴に10エンドが突っ込んでください
[音楽]
あっ
入っとサーフな娘とクマとってくれさあもっと外れすべていますさあ熊野姫はじめまし
たはじめやられているどうするかどうするか恥ずべきれてきま食べて初めて sorry
夏休みも残り少ないですけど皆さん最後で夏を楽しみましょう
じゃん
[音楽]
ん